depuis février le bilan de cette crise
politique est lourd selon certaines
estimations
mille cent vingt civils en réalité
certainement beaucoup plus ont été tués
nombreux sont morts en prison à la suite
de tortures au moins 6000 700 personnes
ont été arrêtées
les familles ne savent ni où elle se
trouve ni même si elles sont encore en
vie dès ce mois de février des élus
légitimes en exil ont formé un
gouvernement provisoire d'union d'unité
nationale ce gouvernement d'unité
nationale il nous faut le soutenir car
il n'y aura pas de solution viable et
démocratique sans lui c'est toute la
raison d'être de cette proposition de
résolution
invités monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement français a procédé à une
reconnaissance du gouvernement d'unité
nationale de birmanie nous ne pouvons
pas abandonner la birmanie le peuple
birman si assoiffés de démocratie si
courageux compte sur yon il se bat seul
et son courage force l'admiration
mes chers collègues si le temps presse
c'est parce que la situation n'évolue
guère favorablement elle pourrait
progressivement prendre le tour d'une
guerre civile marquée par une répression
sévère des autorités militaires d'autant
plus que toutes les grandes ethnies se
retrouve dans le gouvernement d'unité
nationale rien évoluera sans réponse
régionale et la neutralité affichée des
pays de la zone ne saurait être prétexte
à l'inaction
alors monsieur le ministre
cette mesure marque le fait que nous
arrivons à un tournant pour éviter de
glisser vers cette solution de
reconnaissance de facto de la junte il
est je crois indispensable de traiter
avec la seule autorité légitime en
l'état actuel le gouvernement d'unité
nationale et ses représentants pour
réenclenché un processus de transition
démocratique
il est indispensable à la fois que les
nations unies aux perdants bas au total
sur les armes lourdes fournit
essentiellement par la russie et la
chine que soit renforcer le dialogue
avec les aa au les groupements et nick
harmer le cdh le mouvement populaire de
désobéissance civile et bien sûr que
soit reconnu le gouvernement d'unité
nationale